[Music]
hello welcome everyone to the stanford
mba admissions panel
on your journey from stanford to europe
my name is lisa ginanjali and i'm a
director of mba admissions as well as an
alumna of the program
and i'm joined today by some of my
fellow alumni who will share some of
their
experiences both at stanford and now
working and living in europe
you'll see a couple of polls on your
screen throughout today's presentation
we'd really appreciate your input
there and at if at any point you have a
question that you would like to ask
our panelists later on please feel free
to pop that in the
q a box so just to
understand a little bit about what we
will cover in today's event
really our aim is to allow you an
opportunity to
engage with our community and to learn a
little bit more about the stanford gsb
experience
and then also some of the experiences of
our alumni who are now currently living
and working in
europe i'll give a super brief
introduction to our global community
you'll have an opportunity to meet our
panelists
i'll start us off with some q a and then
again we really want to hear your
questions so at any point feel free to
type your question in
to that q a box if you see a question
that someone else has asked that you
particularly like you can click on that
thumbs up symbol and that'll vote that
question up to the top
and we'll try to address as many
questions as we can
in our 55 minutes together today
so where will your journey take you well
a stanford mba can really take you
almost anywhere it's interesting as
students are arriving
to stanford again they're coming from
all around the world
and we see a number of regional clubs on
campus that form and every year there's
a robust group that's in the europe club
on campus similarly after you graduate
this journey can take you again almost
anywhere you want to go
we have approximately 60 regional alumni
clubs all around the world
45 of which are outside of the united
states there are about 30
000 gsb alumni globally and a much much
broader stanford university network
all around the world that you can
absolutely tap into at any point
personally or professionally but let's
take an opportunity now to meet
some of our panelists so we have a
wonderful group today of
uh alumni who are currently living
and working in europe it'd be great if
each of our alums could just briefly
introduce yourselves we'll go in the
order that we see here on the slides and
christina and we'll start with you
sorry yes hi everyone my name is
cristina lamarca i graduated in
summer 18. i currently live in london
where i work at deliverer in a
commercial function prior to going to
stanford i was at mckinsey and company
focusing mostly on food and beverages
it's always been a passion of mine and
in 2019 i moved from new york
to to london so nice to meet you all
hi everybody my name is stephan
hildebrand
i graduated in 16 as you can see there
i'm originally from germany
and lived in the us for a combined 17
years
so i was in the u.s before stanford
mba i worked in new york and had started
a commercial bakery business there
that we then sold and moved back to
germany
right after the nba
and sita i know is joining us yes
yeah hi hi guys nice to virtually meet
all of you
my name is sita um i'm originally from
austria
uh have been abroad for eight years
part of that was uh obviously my time at
the gsb
and right after the gsb took my
then-american boyfriend now husband to
london and then now back to austria
professionally i was in telco before
wanted
to do something with an impact on
climate change did a lot of
energy classes renewable energy classes
at the gsb and then went into
sustainable mobility and i'm now
working with electric vehicles
hi all here's patricia i'm mba 2012
i'm an engineer in education originally
from spain before
the mba i worked in consulting also
mckinsey madrid office
and after the mba i moved to germany
directly
worked with the european central bank
since then for the last eight years in
different functions
now taking care of distributing or bank
notes to all of you or
all of those of you who are in europe
and very happy to be here
hello everyone great to be virtually
meet
everyone uh my name is maxim and i
graduated from stanford
15 years ago a long time ago uh
prior to the university i worked
in private equity as well as corporate
development in telecoms
and after graduation i think i has taken
i have taken three roles first i was the
ceo of
print and press distribution company
then i had
the media holding company in
in in russia and
i think for the over seven years
i one of the shareholders and the
founder of sound
group which is a real estate um
marketplace like uh classifieds and
marketplace
something like zlo.com or rightmove
or maybe let's go 24 for the european
counterparts great to answer questions
today
great thank you all uh so i'll start us
off with some um
questions for our panelists but again we
really also want to hear
from you our attendees so any questions
that you have for our panelists
please feel free to put those in the q a
box and we'll get to those in just a few
minutes
so this first question is really for any
of our panelists anyone who wants to
chime in
uh but why did you decide to pursue an
mba and why specifically at stanford
so for me it was very obvious i was
actually i'm engineers education
and i landed into consulting um for
random
reasons so i always felt like i didn't
really have the background knowledge i
needed so i was learning on the job the
whole time
um which was fun and was interesting but
i felt like i needed
to sort of build up my skills um so an
mba was
was clear why stanford um
for me stanford is very special in the
sense that it allows cross-disciplinary
um training and education and for me
this was very important so as
an engineer who was working in sort of
business world i always felt like one
can add value and innovate when you're
in the middle of two disciplines and i
think stanford does a great job at
allowing that also throughout the mba
program
being on campus is one thing and being
able to take classes across the street
is even better um so for me the decision
was very clear from the beginning um
because of that maxim did you want to
talk about why you decided to do an mba
and why stanford
yeah i think it was very interesting for
me because the reason i
decided to join stanford and the reason
why i
changed my career afterwards are totally
different so
i applied and i got admitted to stanford
with the idea of becoming a
partner in private equity and which
capital uh fund
and obviously stanford is there
the ultimate university for that i would
say
so actually i i think there were two
schools that
were really important for such a career
center and the other school
and actually it was clear
choice for me to go to stanford on that
having said that
over the course of two years i actually
decided to
[Music]
change my kind of profession
i i i spent some internship
working for a vc company in silicon
valley and decided that it's a great
job i would love to do it maybe 20-30
years after graduation but not just
after
the graduation so
so i decided that it's much more fun and
i think it's much more
natural for me to manage people rather
than excel sheets and powerpoints
so i decided that i would go for any job
which
takes managing take responsibility and
manage a lot of people
that's what i did actually attendably
great this next question i'll direct
toward
um stefan and maxim but how have you
connected with or leveraged the alumni
community in europe either personally
speaking
or professionally speaking
yeah i can speak to that a little bit um
i decided to move to germany
with my then pregnant uh wife american
wife
um very unsure how that move would go
for the two of us uh both personally and
professionally
and um in the second year there's a big
push to kind of like start connecting
with alumni
um i think it's a really good starting
point is the alumni database that i
actually
do use quite frequently and i just
started searching
you know for people in germany for
people in munich specifically because we
were going to move to munich at that
point
and i remember and this is a true story
i know it sounds made up but it really
is a true story
um i reached out to a handful of people
in munich
and you know then one of them well
everybody
you know kind of emailed back right away
but one of them said hey that's amazing
that you're moving to
to munich you know would you be at all
interested in you know me hosting a
dinner
so that you can get to know uh you know
a whole bunch alumni at the same time
and i thought that was like
i had no idea where this was coming from
you know i didn't know him um
and he said yeah i'd be happy to do it
so literally after four weeks of being
in germany
uh you know there was a dinner at
somebody's house um
i think there were like 25 people there
or something and
it was an amazing start for me right not
knowing a whole lot of people because i
had never lived in munich i
i grew up in stuttgart but i was gone
for so many years
and it was an amazing introduction into
the kind of like that stanford it really
is like a family in munich right there
aren't
this is not new york or san francisco
where there's just hundreds of alumni
you know there's clearly a a more
limited amount of them
um but they were super open you know
they
they helped right away i mean i've i've
gotten investors through them
a bunch of them invested in our business
um
and um you know i've i've i've
have nothing but good things to say
right again it's it's it's a smaller
network than you will get from some of
the other programs in europe obviously
just by the sheer size of the class and
the geographic location
but the accessibility and the
willingness to help
is is very very high
maxine would you like to share your
experiences connecting with me
yeah i think i'll give three examples of
of my life my
personal story first is about not
professional rather than like
personal i totally echo
stefan's point on the really close
community
in european countries and like more
family style
kind of feeling i would say
we know each of our stanford graduates
be graduates uh
knows each other quite well and like we
get together with the families and like
we can we can go fishing together we can
go and travel
so it really feels like um
similar culture and similar values which
are really important as well as everyone
is uh so kind of open to
to share uh what what he or she has uh
with the rest of the community of this
big community here here in moscow
and i also like traveling around the
globe before
karna virus came about and actually it's
really great to send an email to any of
my classmates and any country in the
world actually
and all get the best experience uh
within that country both from a
professional and from
personal um personal viewpoint and
on on on on the career career-wise
uh gsb uh alumni helped me a lot
first i got my first ceo position
through
gsb network and definitely it is
one of the greatest opportunities that
alumni have got after graduation
and obviously it is uh due to the fact
that we all share the same experience
but
the idea that actually literally within
uh
one day everyone answers your email
because you
also graduate from jsb it's what i have
experienced
a lot um and uh
for example my current uh co-partners at
its internet real estate uh marketplace
and
they are gsbs as well
so they uh they raised over 1 billion
u.s dollars fund from
gpmorgan european pension funds etc
and they were quite uh it but it was
very easy
to for us to to close uh that deal
basically to bring investments to sound
when we decided to raise new uh
new money because i mean they think on
the same they think they say the same
way they also
kind of share the idea of how to build
business
together and i think over the
course of seven years i truly feel that
we are like like-minded we we share the
same ideas and
obviously we have some arguments but we
understand how to resolve them
in a professional manner and that's
definitely
another really important angle to
stanford
community thank you sita i'm actually
going to cold call you i've heard you
talk in the past about
your stanford gsv tribe do you want to
share a little bit about that
yeah happy too so this is uh this is a
post-graduation uh development actually
uh stefan
and i are in the same tribe if i may
share that much
um so we were a bunch of
people who were gonna move away from
californians more specifically to europe
towards the end of end of our time at
the gsb we knew that we were going to go
directly to europe different countries
and we really wanted to stay connected
to sort of the school the thinking that
sort of cultural aspect that maxine was
just talking about
and we just started a group of um
initially i think we had three tribes um
sort of vlad am us and uh europe
ten people each and we just we're still
going strong
five years later we're basically meeting
up about
every quarter um used to be in person
now we've
obviously switched to virtual meetings
and it's just a great way to you know
spend
a good chunk of time together we usually
do like a either a full weekend or a
longer workshop session where we just
kind of
share personal or professional
issues we're struggling with or things
that we want you know
our gsb colleagues input on
and really depending on what people need
if they need coaching if they need
support
you know whatever it is we try
we try to help each other out and kind
of bring that gsb
spirit um into our lives
it's really been it's been such an
enriching experience i'm very very
thankful for it
um takes a lot of um
so you have to really stick with it and
everybody really needs to get a lot of
value out of it because everybody
obviously is starting families and
businesses and has a lot of
different priorities but um people have
really made it a priority
and that's been great great thanks for
sharing uh this next question i'll
direct to um patricia
and um sita can you talk a little bit
more about how you made that transition
from the gsb
to europe and sort of what sorts of
things were most helpful was it
alumni connections or did you do a
summer internship or a
global study trip in europe did you do
class projects with european
companies was it career management
center report how was your path and
and what did you find most helpful in
making that transition maybe patricia is
starting with you
so from my side i mean i have a little
bit of a special career in the sense
that after stanford i went to a public
institution and this was something that
i wanted to do
and i was very clear i wanted to do
already from the start
um so i had to figure a little bit my
way um
out um it's uh i got a lot of support
from the career management center
um we had a special person assigned to
international students back then i don't
know if it's still the case
um and she discussed them with us
in terms of what we wanted to do at
least with me what i wanted to do what
is it exactly that i wanted i mean
public institutions is a very
open domain so was it um in europe was
it not what was it that was important
for me
and really going to the core um i also
leveraged
after understanding what is it exactly
that i want i leveraged a lot on the
alumni database as stefan was mentioning
so really looking through the database
looking for people who had
done similar things like me um also in
europe and
just reaching out getting an answer
immediately
um having phone calls um sort of half
hour chat um just understanding how they
had done it what they liked what they
didn't like what were well
what didn't work so well and just
learning from those experiences
and then starting my own sort of reach
out so i reached out a lot within my two
years
um i would say not only europe actually
because this was not so
clear from the beginning um so i did
also explore other options south america
for example
and also the us um but i i think a lot
of
of the process is really looking or see
seeing it for yourself so really talking
to the companies talking to the people
going to their open days or to their
interview days
um having a chat seeing if it fits um
with you or if it
doesn't and just sort of doing that
trial and
stanford supported me a lot in that
process and really establishing those
individual contacts
um to the people that i wanted it to be
industries and the jobs that i thought
could
could be interesting for me um and sort
of going through that process throughout
the two years until i
i found my my way and the place where i
wanted to be and where i'm actually
now for the last eight nine years almost
now so it was a pretty nice
fit in the end um but i said a very
tailored approach this is what i liked
and i valued a lot it was not about what
i should do or what i was supposed to do
but what i wanted to do me myself is
patricia and this is
for me was a very very very um valued
the support that i got from stanford
and sita yeah i don't know if my video's
still working i i
you guys are all frozen for me but i'll
just keep talking
um so yeah i very similar
and still different to patricia i would
say
also a very entrepreneurial approach
very
many different paths that that i used i
actually started using
the network before the gsb i encourage
all of you guys to think about the time
that
you also still have before you start
your mba
i happened to be in berlin
when some some alum called called me to
congratulate me on getting
an offer from the gsb and i ended up
actually doing an internship with his
company
before i actually moved to california so
that was interesting
um i definitely also did the internship
thing um i actually did two internships
in my in my mba summer which is kind of
unusual i did one
in san francisco at a startup and one in
consulting in europe to sort of
keep my options open uh did get an offer
to return
um so sort of that sort of safety
safety thing um was was kind of nice to
to know that
there is also the sort of more
consulting and corporate
uh path that you can follow um
i did do a class research sort of
project
and i also did a lot of alum reach outs
and then actually took the spring break
um to go to go to london which was my
sort of destination i was looking for
so all of these things and then in the
end my the the job that i actually ended
up taking came from a
uh sort of different u.s schools
um mailing lists where sort of the
different marketing clubs were sending
each other
opportunities that obviously i wouldn't
have gotten if i wasn't at one of those
schools
um and yeah just hit it off hit it off
with the people at the company
um so yeah any anything any of those
different things could have worked um
yeah
i would definitely encourage you to look
at to look at the time before your mba
good advice uh this next question i'll
direct to
uh christina and stefan how do you think
a stanford mba differentiates you in the
european marketplace or
maybe just even changes your approach to
how you
solve problems or see opportunities
christina maybe starting with you
um yeah sure so i work at the library
and um i joined about four months ago
six months ago
um and one thing that i noticed as soon
as i started obviously meeting people
was that
um you know there's a big share of
leadership that actually has a stanford
mba
um and you know obviously like you know
some are more
um senior alumni than others uh but it
was pretty sort of like
um interesting for me to notice how you
know
coming from the u.s where like you know
so easy to find a stand for mba like you
know
i landed on this company and then there
they were and
um and even when i was looking at other
options then they
were like you know was always through
stanford alumni
who ended up also having a lot of
leadership positions there so
um you know i think that obviously
sort of like was encouraging as i was
looking for new opportunities in europe
um and then in terms of like how how
difference
not maybe differentiate you but like how
does a stanford mba shape the way you
think
about your job or issues i think
um you know something that i retained
from a lot of the classes that i took
was sort of like
um always going back to your aspiration
of what leader you want to be and so a
lot of the decisions that i take in my
day-to-day whether it's with restaurant
partners
working at the library or it's like with
my own employees it's like
really trying to go back to the set of
principles that i think stanford really
helped me
tease out over those two years
and stefan um how do you think the
stanford mba differentiates you or how
you approach
things uh i think there's two elements i
think there's the
kind of like general interest
from people in europe in silicon valley
and i think maxim mentioned earlier
right that stanford is kind of like at
the epicenter of it
so that's uh that's a given but that
does make you
a i don't want to say a desirable person
but
i you know i have a lot of meetings
where people are super curious about
silicon valley and
like different approaches to things um
and it's a very good starting point
you know if you're trying to connect
with somebody that you might not
otherwise
you know be able to get in touch with or
something like that that kind of like
general high let's talk about silicon
valley and what i learned there and what
i saw there
is always a really really good starting
point and it's something that people are
generally interested in
um the other thing to me
is i think it's more of a personal thing
i
you know was always under the impression
before the mba that
i could learn hard skills through like
many
you know different avenues and i
really focus on soft skill development
at stanford
i think stanford itself pushes you in
that direction
a lot but that was super important to me
and i think that's that's a very big
differentiating factor from what i can
tell
to other mba programs as well and again
i obviously didn't attend those but
just when talking to a lot of alumni you
know
i certainly have a very different
approach um
to kind of like leadership as christina
mentioned just now you know it's like a
very
kind of like let's get it behind a
shared vision let's do it together
um you know i'm i think i'm much more
aware of how
i come across to others than i was in
the past
i never really thought about it you know
because nobody ever told me that i
should
quite frankly and you know there's a lot
of like
uh things and you know kind of like also
this silicon valley approach of that
it's okay to fail
um that we've definitely implemented in
our company and
we're not worried about it and i think
it might be different in other european
countries but in germany there's
certainly a stigma
a very negative stigma around failure um
and we've made it completely okay
obviously
under the right circumstances and
that's helped us tremendously you know
we've been able to
achieve things that i don't think we
would have
with another culture all right
this next question i'll pose to ansita
and christina
any favorite gsb courses or experiences
or resources that you continue to
leverage today
sita maybe we'll start with you yeah um
very diverse set of classes it's always
the classes that you don't
you can never know which ones will be it
will come in handy ten years after
after the fact that's the the weird one
um
the the ones that were sort of obvious
to me because that was my reason to or
one of the big things for me is was this
shift to renewables and climate change i
took a lot of energy classes across
the street so in the stanford university
not not the business school
um that's obviously been been a huge
um helping factor in in just being
knowledgeable about the space that i
wanted to enter
also helped me understand that i
personally wasn't going to be coming in
as
a business undergrad i personally wasn't
going to become an
engineer or a masters in engineering but
i got enough
knowledge out of it to to know that i
had a place in that world
um and then i could sort of talk to the
topics
other gsb classes that
really stuck with me were around hr and
leadership and not not so much the
sort of the ones that i knew were gonna
be great that everybody talks about but
also the ones that
um are a little bit more tangible and
hands-on there was something
i don't know the the colloquial term was
hiring and firing um
a really hands-on class that
i think about every single time i have a
sort of managerial topic
coming up um with
power was it was a surprising one that
really
really helped me come come out of my
shell and and then try a different
leadership style that
that i think about a lot uh and weirdly
a statistics class that i also end up
you know every time somebody comes to me
with some sort of
fact or stat or i read an article in the
news i i
question it in a very different way than
i than i used to
christina how about you any favorite gsb
courses or experiences that you continue
to leverage today
um yeah so um i actually
so when i was a gsb i took two sales
classes
because uh if there was one thing that
was felt very uncomfortable was
negotiations um and i had this almost
like tip on my shoulder so i went i did
the two classes and after that i was
like you know this was great i'll never
get
into like a sales role and here i am
like you know global commercial
delivery um and it's funny because
um you know i go back to those classes
every day
as in like you know beyond the tools
that
you know you could think like well maybe
i can get them and you know there's
plenty of sales classes and so on it was
more like
the approach in which those tools were
offered to us and so a lot of
live sort of like cases and
simulations and then similarly i took
classes like managing difficult
conversations managing growing
enterprises where again it's like you
prepare a case
uh you know you're called out and you
have to like basically act pretty much
and be
right in and on the moment and you know
in the role that i have
seen at a negotiation table with you
know counterparts lawyers and like and
it's everything is in the moment
um i've gone so much back to it i've
written back to professors
uh you know telling them about something
that had happened and what was their
perspective so
um you know definitely helpful probably
in the most unexpected way
unexpected way because i didn't think i
was gonna get a role
similar to those classes but um yeah
it's been great this next question
i'll have uh maxim start with that
anyone else who wants to chime in
is more than welcome to uh what advice
would you give to someone who would like
to go to europe
and directly after the stanford tsb
i think uh cetera covered that a little
bit already
it also worked out in my in my situation
uh
i think sita mentioned about networking
prio to jsb
so basically if you
consider such an option to come back to
europe and
or your home country anywhere in the
world it's
uh both talking to people
before jsb during summer breaks winter
breaks
and just stay in touch with people helps
a lot
just understand what's going on on their
site both
like within your friends community your
previous employers
just being in the loop and understand
what's going on
uh helps a lot and besides that i i'm
not sure
how it works out in other countries
in moscow it was a really close
community of
the applicants applying for the major us
graduate school of businesses mba
programs
and we actually got friends and i've got
a lot of friends during
uh that period we just applied together
to different universities and like i got
admitted to stanford somebody got
admitted to other great universities
and we came back and we just our kids
are friends now
and uh it it it's just fun just
talking to the people who share
the same ideas and have the same like
backgrounds
and also i i also uh
did this tour uh among different
business schools prior
to my uh application and a few of the
russian guys who studied at harvard at
wharton
and chicago at that time who
at stanford obviously uh who were like
one two years prior to
to my graduation they also became
friends of mine
since that trip so there is uh at least
one piece of advice just network allowed
within this community prior enduring
jsbs
and the second one i personally believe
that
stanford has great resources uh although
i
uh truly at this 15 years ago it was the
case
that i relied more on myself rather than
on like official venues
if i would love to work back in the home
country in russia
and uh i definitely decided that i
graduated first and then come back and
then start
looking for a job rather than trying to
kind of trying to do both like uh
fighting during the day working during
the night
trying to find a job during like summer
[Music]
summer window or trying to find a job
during morning hours
it doesn't work out so i prefer just to
focus more on
understanding um the classes and like
learning some
something talking and like partnering
with my friends during gsb
and then i graduated come back and then
i started actually looking for
for a new job like seriously
anyone else have advice christina yeah
yeah i can jump in so
um i actually did look into moving to
europe right after gsb and so i took
through the summer in between the two
years the opportunity to come to london
for a week
um obviously done sort of like a bit of
prep work up front a bit like you know
maybe what industries i
and it was very by the way like it's not
that i had very clear like it has to be
consumer or attack like
i was very sort of like wide spectrum of
things that i saw myself doing because
also that's what you
do an mba for sort of like understanding
that uh
um so my my advice would be start
early and you know um every you know
the schedule is busy at the gst but
there's always you know that one week or
you know and you don't even have to be
in the place but just like allocate time
early enough
um and i did keep in touch with the
alumni that i had
pinked during that summer uh because i
think one thing to remember is that
like alumni are like people and they're
very nice people and they like to stay
in touch like you're not just simply
asking them for a job you're making a
human connection so i found that
a lot of you alumni i stayed in touch
with and then
i actually couldn't quit use them
leverage them
as i was deciding whether i wanted to go
back immediately or not
um in in sort of like understanding you
know what was best for me and so
i ended up taking a job in the us so i
didn't move
straight after uh but when i
then was back in london it took me two
weeks to find a new job and i had like
plenty of opportunities so it was very
much like
yeah some would say start early you
don't have to go to them and say you're
100 sure you're going to move to europe
like you know be transparent people are
not expecting you to
you know take any decision during your
first year and so that gives you a lot
of freedom
i think um in shaping your career after
gb
great thank you uh well many of your
responses
have addressed some of the the questions
that we have from our audience um but i
want to
specifically dive into some of those now
that are open for anyone to answer
uh we have a question here of it's sort
of twofold
what was the most unexpected or
impactful
experience during your time at stanford
and maybe what was one of the more
challenging
experiences so who would like to tackle
one of those
i can say in terms of unexpected um
if somebody then wants to take the next
one um there's touchy feely as a class
which everybody i mean which
tamper is very famous for um and there
are a lot of people who go to stanford
and who are just 100 sure they would
participate in that class and that's one
of the big events of their stanford
program
i was not on that line of thinking i was
more on the line of thinking of if
everybody does it
i will not um so i didn't take it until
the end actually when i had a little bit
of fear of missing out
in the last semester and i registered
just in case
um there was something important
happening there and
although i resisted through the first
classes where i was still trying to get
convinced about the idea i have to say
for me
and very surprisingly it was one of the
best experiences i've done
not only at stanford but also i would
say beyond stanford
the level of connection um
human connection so it's it's not really
about content it's it's really about
relationship
um the level of human connection that we
experienced um
during that class and the conversations
we could
or we managed to have on a
person-to-person
basis trying to understand that stefan
was saying how you come across
and how others see you which you maybe
not have considered until now because
you
never just thought about it this i found
the most i have to say after the two
years the most
powerful and and unexpected um event uh
for me at least from my
the the many classes that i took at the
gsp
the other unexpected surprises or
impactful experiences folks want to
highlight
i think i i've got three unexpected
surprises
that i would probably share with you
first i
didn't expect such a beautiful beautiful
nature around the stanford university
and just going out in the woods and
like tahoe lake and the mountains and
ocean in close proximity
and with that definitely made difference
for me
and for my family and the second one
i would say that i i came with a
son of mine to and my spouse to the
campus and
i didn't expect kindergarten and schools
of such a high quality there i
i definitely recommend for those who
would come
with families to consider that option
like on the stanford campus
and the third
there are so many things happening and
uh we were told uh
when we approached when when we came
on the first day that uh it is really
important for us to
kind of to build the skill how to manage
uh
our schedule right both including
sleeping and like
networking and so many clubs so many
classes so many
great people you wanna talk to it's like
uh drinking from firehose i would say
and it's definitely one of the first
abilities uh
i had to to manage in order to survive
basically i didn't expect that
but it helped a lot after graduation as
well
i can quickly jump in um
uh i before the gsb
my life was pretty like you know
straight line right like i did like
economics undergrad i
you know had a company and things like
this and
so in terms of unexpected impactful
things
um i was very hesitant to take kind of
like strange
classes that like right like didn't just
like you know check off my boxes of
this is you know has a 101 correlation
to make me a better whatever manager
leader or something like this
the best class in my opinion
um was a mindfulness class that i took
i don't even know what department it
wasn't the gsb i went in there
on the advice of my wife who said you
should really do this
and i said okay when will i ever do this
other than now and sita knows me well
that's why she's laughing
and i loved it and if there's one piece
of advice and i don't know if this is my
place to give you advice now but
um you know i would drop your
expectations
and not just focus on you know the
things that you think have a one-on-one
correlation to making you more
successful
whatever your goal is richer or more
powerful like
take those two years and literally you
know pump the brakes for just one second
read the whatever you know 100 uh
electives especially in the second year
that you can take
and just take some crazy ones that just
interest you
and what's the worst thing that can
happen to you you go to two classes and
then you just like
don't go for the rest of the semester
you know i wish i would have done
a lot more of that um and in terms of
the challenge
that is kind of like also the challenge
right because once you start doing that
there aren't going to be two classes
that you're kind of interested in
there's going to be 25
and they're all it's 25 a semester you
know so you have to just be okay
with saying look like i'd love to or i'm
kind of interested in these 25
you know but i can only do two because
otherwise my schedule is so crazy that
i'm missing out on a million other
things
any other challenging experiences during
your time at stanford
i think the challenge is uh always not
being dragged by what a lot of people do
or like what you i think what um
we're just talking about um sort of like
what you think is going to be good for
you and for your career
um and sort of like staying grounded
in what you're trying to achieve and
that also becomes sometimes very sort of
like
confused and foggy and so you know it's
a lot
at the time i felt that i was almost
sort of like
getting lost and not getting the most
out of it and then now a couple of years
out i actually realized that that's
actually the process you're meant to go
through like you don't go
to the gsb because you have it all clear
um if anything is an opportunity to like
admit that not everything is super clear
also life doesn't go
always as you planned it so there's um
there's that element and that becomes
even more
true as you you know graduate and life
moves on for a lot of your classmates
um and so i think the challenge in the
moment is always
sort of like being mindful of that and
not getting scared of not
starting doubting yourself then maybe
you're not doing enough or too much and
you know they always say you can either
sleep and not
go to the party or finish your
assignments and get a good grade or like
you know go to class it's just like
there's too much to do that sometimes it
gets overwhelming
this next question um maybe um cedaw
have you start
um and stefan you might have a
perspective too having spent i think you
said 17 years in the u.s but we're
seeing some
questions from panelists um if you are
not originally a european citizen or if
you're coming from another part of the
world
and want to transition to europe
you know is that possible and maybe you
can even reflect um all of you on your
your peers and your colleagues and your
classmates um you know
in your various home countries do you
see uh
non-european citizens who are now
currently working
in europe um who are gsb grads and ceta
i called on you because of your personal
connection there yeah
yeah i'm happy to share so uh
this was my unexpected i didn't want to
put it in the challenge or unexpected
thing but i i
so i met my husband at the gsb um who's
an american
uh i thought i wanted to come back to
europe after the gsp
met this american guy uh unexpected not
what i had planned um yeah
he the way he did it was he
had worked in his summer in the summer
internship he
worked for a then
a us-based startup um
in product and they were just in the
process of expanding to
to europe and he basically got an offer
from them for the silicon valley
office but then managed to transfer that
over
um to the uk so they were sponsoring him
so that's one of the paths that i know
pretty well
um obviously we've since gotten married
so that's
another thing that is sometimes possible
and sometimes obviously not
um the other thing that he also did so i
mentioned that i had an offer from a
consulting firm
that i had worked with and so we tried
amsterdam over the summer by the way
and then decided we wanted to move to
london so there was another
um little thing there obviously try
whatever you can but consulting is
um obviously has global recruiting and
they obviously know how to do all of the
the visa things so that's that's a
fairly
safe one i would say you can even you
know
do an internship in one city get an
offer transfer that offer
or you know apply directly with the
office that you want to go to so
that's how i how i went to amsterdam and
we we would have been able to go to
london with with that as well
um other friends yeah unfortunately i'm
aware of a few of our classmates who
um stayed in the us but didn't like
in the former uh president's era didn't
manage to
quite stay uh longer uh some of them
have come to europe i don't know exactly
the visa situation but it seemed to be
significantly easier obviously than
staying in the us at the time i think
hopefully that'll
uh loosen up in the future
but those are those are the things i i
can think of right now
and do anything just add like one or two
more things
i mean apart from immigration things
right which i i don't know anything
about how difficult that is but
um i think like cedar said for sure big
companies right are always a good
starting point
um and i can just talk for a you know
little munich as my wife calls it
she's from new york so it's very little
to her
but even there right there's plenty of
english speaking opportunities as well
so that's clearly not an issue in london
or you know any of the other bigger
cities but
um so even the language thing i think um
you know because that's a big one uh for
a lot of people um
you can do without i mean my wife did
not speak a word of german when we moved
um
and she now speaks some but i don't
think that should be a huge
concern um but i i would come back to
the alumni right that's the first
starting point
i mean there's there's there's plenty of
alumni
in you know whatever important powerful
positions
in in virtually every big city so if
there's a
a larger city that you're interested in
or a company you're interested in right
with somebody from another office
um i would start there and i'm sure
you know if you're serious about wanting
to move to europe um
there's opportunities that the stanford
network can help identify together with
you
and um you know you can then then make
the move
i mean we have several just coming back
to this tribe that sido was talking
about earlier our little
10 person group here in europe there are
americans
uh several americans on it that you know
moved to europe and are now still here
and uh
part of our group so it's you know it's
definitely a longer term
alternative also for people
we have a question here from an audience
member
obviously there are a number of
wonderful european business schools as
well i don't know if any of you were
considering those but what
are the things that you felt you could
only learn
um doing your mba in the us or maybe the
gsb in particular
i have like i'll just oh sorry go go go
okay i'll quickly do mine um this was
the reason for me to to decide to go to
stanford um so i visited a couple
different schools and
the one thing for me is that
at stanford you have the protagonist of
the case
sitting there in front of you and
telling you the story and all of the
backstory behind it and that to me was
just the
you know i can read a case at home i can
think about what i would do and i could
maybe discuss it with some smart people
but
hearing from you know the founder or
something
about the struggle they were facing and
what really went on behind the scenes
the things that they maybe didn't
necessarily put in the case that's the
kind of learning where i thought you
know i can only get that here like
that's
this is the this is silicon valley like
a lot of the alums are
still around and that just blew my mind
i think until i done that sorry it's
true but like
um it took a class in which they invited
so there were two co-founders that
started a company then
um they separated uh not in sort of like
great terms and the professor invites
both of them into different days and
you like hear both vows which is like
you know it almost
gets uncomfortable for the class to hear
right because it's like
you hear one and then you feel like
you're on their side and then
you go and you hear the other one it's
just like i think i agree
um i mean it's one of the elements that
made me pick somebody
um the other one for me was um i
wanted to get a bit of the like silicon
valley experience which
in in reality for me meant like you know
do something that i've never done i
started a shoe company
uh while at stanford then like my family
is absolutely not entrepreneurial so for
me was uh
going way like out of my comfort zone
and then in silicon valley there were
all these people so excited about
me and my business but yeah um the case
was definitely
one of the big big things for me that
made me pick stamford
patricia so for me
so the mba is either one year or two
year program so it's quite a long time
and i felt it was a long time
to not work actually um and not make a
professional career so i wanted to make
the best out of it
and for me going to the u.s especially
going to stanford and silicon valley
also meant the cultural experience
so it's one thing to get the class and
to understand your statistical concepts
and
even the case and discuss it but it's
another thing to experience how
life is in silicon valley how people
think how people
behave breathe i mean there's a lot of
different elements that are subjective
that you don't really
measure or not written on paper that i
would not have gotten if i would not
have gone to stanford
um and for me that was the one of the
key elements in taking the decision
to really have this this comprehensive
experience so not only classes but
going beyond beyond that
great thank you well i do want to be
mindful of the time as i know we're
coming up on
our uh end point here again you'll see
another poll pop
up momentarily and we'd love to to get
your input there
i want to absolutely thank all of our
panelists for sharing your experiences
today both
about your time at the gsb as well as
your time now currently
in europe i think it was very very
helpful to to hear about that transition
and how you made that transition
for all of our attendees today we hope
that this is just the start
of your stanford mba journey and a
wonderful way to continue that journey
is through a site called mystanford.mba
please check this out if you haven't
already there's an opportunity to create
your own personalized dashboard there
it will tee up clubs and courses that
might be of interest to you
student or alumni profiles that might
resonate with you if you start an
application you can track your
application progress there and it will
also suggest
other events that might be of interest
to you such as the one today
so again thank you to our panelists
thank you to all of our attendees i hope
you've enjoyed today's session
and best of luck in your mba journey
you